from rumors of a rivalry to fashion
comparisons and realities about their
relationship we're breaking down Megan
Markell and Kate Middleton's bonds on
spillin the royalty Meghan Markel and
Kate Middleton are about to become
family bonding here on tepee so here's
everything we know about their royal
relationship there have been rumours of
feuding some say issues over who would
be thought of as the next Princess Diana
or problems about Harry and Megan's
wedding possibly upstaging Will and
Kate's but we have never gotten any info
that any of that is true in fact a
source tells et quote Kate has been
doing whatever she can to help Megan
adjust to life behind palace walls megan
has also been leaning on Kate for advice
remember Kate and Megan are even the
same age and our source says Kate is
helping Megan get accustomed to life in
the public eye like how the paparazzi
now follow her and how she's had to
adjust to having a smaller inner circle
as a royal then people either want to
paint them as best friends or present
them as enemies and I don't think
they're either actually they're getting
to know each other
kate is an incredibly kind person
whenever I've met her she is genuinely
nice in fact et's reporting is that all
the women of the royal family kate
Camilla and the Queen embrace Megan when
you look at Megan on paper she is not
necessarily what you might expect of a
conventional royal fiance and that she's
American she's a well-known face she's
filmed some pretty racy sex scenes that
we've all seen in suits you know
everything from being a divorcee to
being a bit older than Prince Harry to
coming from a Geo heritage family you
know you might wonder if the Queen being
of a certain generation and of course
being the Queen might have been at all
concerned but everything I heard from
the sources I spoke to was that she
really felt from the outset that Megan
was a positive person in Prince Harry's
actress Megan was used to life on the
red carpet but she has had to make some
fashion adjustments in the royal family
like wearing tights and embracing
British designers we've learned Kate is
helping Megan with all of that at one
event they even wore the same shoes Plus
Megan and Harry have been living close
to Will and Kate and we're told Megan
loves being an aunty she spent Christmas
with George and Charlotte and our source
says since Megan loves to cook she pops
by her future in-laws house with treats
for the little ones
so what do you think are Megan and Kate
becoming close friends do you believe
they'll be as close as sisters let me
know cheerio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]